hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome back to the paranormal August no
I don't have time for that something
like a sham blur back downstairs before
that just ended the game I was assuming
there would be all sorts of new stuff
but apparently there is not back what is
that a bird oh okay yeah it's a freaking
bird now we get to the news that's a
basement all right maybe I'll run out of
battery life and I don't know what
happens I probably die I run out of
battery on the last day to makes total
sense
okay I go oh I'll go to the oh I'll go
to the basement again Nick
[Music]
hmm oh I guess so all right fine ah that
happened before that didn't happen
before right wait a minute
no this is what I did before when I was
gonna blow up the house I'm not gonna do
that this time I'm not gonna do it what
is there it's kind of right in front of
my eyeballs did I die no I did not die
but I lost my battery indicator I
couldn't see what that was oh I didn't
know my flashlight did I
hello December 29 Oh ty ain't nobody got
time for that
what done oh good oh no oh oh
[Music]
good god no again man I must be
invincible I'm so yeah funk oh yeah
apparently I'm like the strongest guy
okay so I know that the other way blows
up the house burns it all down there
quickly and I don't one-up burning down
what is that a key key Hey no keys keys
all over the place this guy's hosed to
do with this something in it burn it
just like an ax
what's that hey I saw that
oh no I guess I have no choice I must
burn the house down
question mark like I swear this really I
was expecting like so much more to be
added to the game maybe I shouldn't have
gone to the big should I have gone to
the basement just let me know if I click
on the face right final burn the friggin
house down okay I sound like a bird no
is that okay now the gas leaking well
what does that do for me Oh
[Music]
ah yeah whoo I see you I couldn't do
don't you have to draw that's right oh
damn it that's the same ending I got
[Music]
and then it'll just blow this up I don't
know I was expecting like you know when
a game goes to full release and it's
said that there was so much more I was
expelling a fire the house one set of
human remains was found basement of the
home the nature of the fire appears to
be gas related there was no difference
between Olympus get it through words and
I played before in the unabridged and
the abridgement identify I don't know
what the difference was it didn't even
seem like there was a difference I don't
know maybe I'm missing something maybe
I'm missing something I think I feel
like I'm out of the loop on a tragedy
why is it just white that's it it's
ridiculous it's just white like that
I thought thump something would have
changed I don't know I don't know what
the deal is I don't know I'm kind of I'm
kind of angry that it hasn't changed
because I was expecting more and there's
still no save or anything like that
you're gonna start from the beginning
each time and then ramp up so there's no
potential to just get in there I don't
know I don't know I might be missing
something if I am missing something let
me know in the comments below
other than that I got nothing else to
show ya so thank you so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye